[Music]
[Applause]
it's a bit funny to be at a conference
dedicated to things not seen and present
my proposal to build a 6 000 kilometer
long wall across the entire african
continent
about the size of the great wall of
china this would hardly be an invisible
structure and yet it's made from parts
that are invisible or near invisible to
the naked eye bacteria and grains of
sand
now as architects were trained to solve
problems but i don't really believe in
architectural problems i only believe in
opportunities which is why i'll show you
a threat
and an architectural response
the threat is death certification
my response
is a sandstone wall made from
bacterially solidified sand stretching
across the desert
now sand is a magical material of
beautiful contradictions it is simple
and complex
it is peaceful and violent it is always
the same never the same endlessly
fascinating one billion grains of sand
come into existence in the world each
second
that's a cyclical process as rocks and
mountains die grains of sand are born
some of those grains may then cement
naturally into sandstone as the
sandstone weathers new grains break free
some of those grains may then accumulate
on a massive scale
into a sand dune
in a way
the static stone mountain becomes a
moving mountain of sand
but moving mountains can be dangerous
let me try and explain
why
dry areas cover more than one third of
the earth's land surfaces some are
already deserts others are being
seriously degraded by the sand
just south of the sahara we find to say
hell the name means edge of the desert
and this is the region most closely
associated with the certification it was
here in the late 60s and early 70s
that major droughts
brought three million people to become
dependent upon emergency food aid with
about up to 250 000 dying
this is a catastrophe waiting to happen
again and it's one that gets very little
attention in our accelerated media
culture
their certification is simply too slow
to reach the headlines it's nothing like
a tsunami or a katrina too few crying
children and smashed up houses
and yet death certification
is a major threat on all continents
affecting some 110 countries
and about 70 percent of the world's
agricultural dry lands
it seriously threatens the livelihoods
of millions of people
and especially in africa and china
and it is largely an issue that we've
created for ourselves through
unsustainable use of scarce resources
so we get climate change we get droughts
increased desertification crashing food
systems water scarcity
famine
forced migration
political instability
warfare crisis that's a potential
scenario if we fail to take this
seriously
but how far away is it i went to sokoto
in northern nigeria to try and find out
how how far away it is
the dunes here move southward at a pace
of around 600 meters a year that's the
sahara eating up almost one meter a day
of the arable land physically pushing
people away from their homes
here i am on the second person on the
left
with the elders in
a tiny village outside of sokoto
they had to move this village in 1987 as
a huge dune threatened to swallow it so
they moved the entire village hot by
heart
and this is where the village used to be
it took us about 10 minutes to climb up
to the top of that tune which goes to
show why they had to move to a safer
location
that's the kind of forced migration that
death certification can lead to
if you happen to live close to the
desert border you can pretty much
calculate how long it will be before you
have to carry your kids away and abandon
your home and your life as you know it
now
sand dunes cover only about one fifth of
our deserts and still those extreme
environments are very good places if we
want to stop the shifting sounds
four years ago 23 african countries came
together to create the great green wall
sahara a fantastic project the initial
plan called for a shelter belt of trees
to be planted right across the african
continent from mauritania in the west
all the way to djibouti in the east if
you want to stop a sand dune from moving
what you need to make sure to do is to
stop the grains from avalanching over
its crest and a good way of doing that
the most efficient way is to use some
kind of sand catcher trees or cacti are
good for this
but one of the problems with planting
trees is that the people in these
regions are so poor that they chop them
down for firewood
now there's
an alternative to just planting trees
and hoping that they won't get chopped
down so the sandstone wall that i'm
proposing essentially does three things
it adds a roughness to the dune surface
to the texture of the dune surface
binding the grains it provides a
physical support structure for the trees
and it creates physical spaces habitable
spaces inside of the sand dunes if
people live inside of the green barrier
they can help support the trees protect
them from humans and from some of the
forces of nature
inside of the dunes we find shade you
can start harvesting condensation and
start greening the desert from within
sand dunes are almost like ready-made
buildings in a way all we need to do is
solidify the pods that we need to be
solid and then excavate the sand
and we have our architecture we can
either excavate it by hand we can have
the wind excavated for us so the wind
carries the sand onto the site and then
it carries the redundant sand away from
the structure for us
but by now you're probably asking how am
i planning to solidify your sand dune
how do we glue those grains of sand
together and the answer is perhaps that
you use these guys
bacillus pasteuri a microorganism that
is readily available in wetlands and
marshes and does precisely that it takes
a pile of loose sand and it creates
sandstone out of it
these images from the american society
for microbiology shows the process what
happens is you pour bacillus posterior
onto a pile of sand and it starts
filling up the voids in between the
grains so chemical process produces
calcite which is kind of natural cement
that binds the grains together the whole
cementation process takes about 24 hours
i learned about this from a professor at
uc davis called jason de jong he managed
to do it in in a mere 1400 minutes
here i am playing the part of the mad
scientist working with the bugs at ucl
in london
trying to solidify them so how much
would this cost
um
i'm not an economist very much now but i
did quite literally back of the envelope
calculation
and um
it seems that for a cubic meter of
concrete we would have to pay in the
region of 90
and after an initial cost of 60 bucks to
buy the bacteria which you never have to
pay again
one cubic meter of bacterial sound would
be about 11
how do we construct something like this
well i'll quickly show you two options
the first is to create a kind of balloon
structure fill it with bacteria then
allow the sand to wash over the balloon
pop the balloon as it were disseminating
the bacteria into the sun and
solidifying it then a few years
afterwards using permacultural
strategies we've greened that part of
the desert the second alternative would
be to use injection piles so we push the
piles down through the dune and we
create an initial bacterial surface we
then pull the piles up through the dune
and we're able to create almost any
conceivable shape inside of the sand
with the sand acting as a mold as we go
up
so we have a way of turning sand into
sandstone and then creating these
habitable spaces
inside of the desert genes but what
should they look like
well i i based i i was inspired for my
architectural form by tophoney which
looked a little bit like this this is a
model representation of it these are
cavernous rock structures that i found
on the site in socato and i realized if
i scaled them up they would provide me
with good um spatial qualities for
ventilation for thermal comfort and for
for other things now
part of the
formal control over this structure would
be lost to nature obviously as the
bacteria do their work
and i think this creates a kind of
boundless beauty actually i think
there's really something in that
articulation that that is quite nice um
we see the result the traces if you like
of the bacillus posterior being
harnessed to sculpt the desert into
these habitable environments some people
believe that
this would
spread uncontrollably and that the
bacteria would kill everything in its
way that's not true at all it's a
natural process it goes on in nature
today and the bacteria die as soon as we
stop feeding them so there it is
architectural anti-desertification
structures made from the desert itself
sand stopping devices made from sand
the world is likely to lose one-third of
its terrible land by the end of the
century
in a period of
unprecedented population growth and
increased food demands this could prove
disastrous and quite frankly we're
putting our heads in the sun
nothing else i would like for this
scheme to initiate a discussion
but if i had something like a ted wish
it would be to actually get it built to
start building this habitable wall this
very very long
but very narrow
city in the desert built into the
dunescape itself
it's
not only something that supports tree
but something that connects people and
countries together
i would like to conclude
by showing you an animation of the
structure
and
leave you
with a sentence by by showing borges
said
that nothing is built
on stone
everything is built on sand
but we must build as if the sand were
stoned
now there are many details left
to explore in the scheme political
practical
ethical financial
my
design
as it takes you down the rabbit hole
is fraught
with many challenges
and difficulties in the real world
but it's a beginning
it's a vision
as barcas would have it it's the sun
and i think now
is really the time to turn it into stone
thank you
traffic is a global epidemic
us traffic is creating 45 percent of the
world's air pollution in the uk time
wasted in traffic costs 20 billion a
year would you pay for cleaner air on a
faster commute stockholm put it to a
vote i voted for it yes i voted for it i
vote for it we're not old enough to vote
vote
we had to do something in stockholm to
improve the environment and to get a
better flow in the traffic we put a
price on taking your car into the
central parts of stockholm and we call
that congestion charges
if you start a system like this and it
doesn't work on the first day
then you will be in big trouble
it must be perfect from day one
there are 18 empty gates to the city
each is equipped with cameras pictures
are taken of the rear and front license
plates these pictures are sent to a
central system that identifies the
license plates and makes sure that the
right person pays for the right passages
one of the obstacles we overcame was the
ocr the optical character reading of the
license plate we went out to ibm's
global organization and the r d centers
and find a very good software we could
use and we managed to implement it in
two months time this is the heart of the
system where all images and passages are
being processed over 99 of all pictures
are correctly identified
so it's nice this is how it should be
all the time
behind me you can see the traffic and
the clock is 6 pm before we had the
congestion charging the traffic was
chewing up at this time of the day
i think it's a good idea because i think
that we should take care of the
environment in the city the traffic went
down with about 22 percent and the air
pollution was about 14 better
it's a huge international interest from
different parts of the world from
the united states from latin america
from china and it's
really a pleasure to tell people not
what we are planning to do but what we
actually have done in stockholm i voted
for it yes i did not my husband so
but i did i think he is not thinking
like me for
the future i'm thinking for the children
and the grandchildren
[Music]